all right sorry about that everybody
that iPhone lied to me about what it's
orientation was and then that screwed
everything up with me
err there we go okay Hank we're up and
running now oh I am really sorry about
that I really wish there was a way to
like restart a live stream without
having to completely end the darn stupid
thing and start over that's that's
really irritating
ah yes even do you as well hey there's
an dear hope I'm pronouncing that right
I only ever seen it written rip written
written boy we're off to a wonderful
start here I need you fellows thankful
for his water oh well yeah a little bit
tell you what though I am uh I'm
thankful for warm bathrobes
that's what I'm thankful for making me
think of a second doctor ha ha ha ha
so yeah it's not a coat it's a bathroom
this actually I'm kind of sneaking this
in a little bit because I actually
bought this and I keep this at my house
for Liz cuz she gets cold so much we
call this the wildling robe cuz I
reminds us a bit of oh god what was her
name I want to say it gret from Game of
Thrones the one who shot Jon Snow in the
back are you aware of the no BS channels
Twitter account being raided with
posters from g-force it's amazing there
are multiple words right in that
question that I don't know what they
mean haha so sorry I got nothing there
warm bath robes are my way of saving
money on heat yeah this house in Vermont
no
cheap to heat so how you doing doing all
right not too bad love the Rope thank
you did you hear that
on Onision got banned from patreon
I didn't cuz I don't know who that is I
feel like people expect because I'm a
creator that I'm much more familiar with
like all the the creators even vaguely
similar to what I do except I'm really
not cuz it I'm making stuff instead of
watching other people stop so yeah I
just don't know well I got Disney Plus
I'm liking it so far but I wish they had
more of the vintage shorts oh do they
not have much of those on there that's
annoying
oh well yes you must know all of the
creators and the patients yes personally
we all we all gather for water ah okay
boomer uh-huh robe would make Slughorn
proud ooh not sure that's the person I
want to impress but I do like this thing
what do you think of the new Doctor Who
trailer was there another one from the
one I did a video on Sunday because if
not I dedicated a video to it already I
can't believe that james rolfe is a fan
of Aqua team Aqua Teen Hunger Force
james rolfe is um he's angry video game
nerd right yeah I could buy that not to
my knowledge like like there's some but
I don't see every single one also not
sure what to make of the mandalorian
honestly I've seen the first three
episodes of the mandalorian and my
stance I hasn't really changed I think
it's well made I'm not sure that I like
it but it's one of those instances where
the reasons I don't like it don't make
it
bad they just make it not for me if that
makes sense and that's not saying not
like is an overstatement I'm liking it
well enough that I'm gonna stick with it
I plan to watch the series through but I
don't love it but I can't nobody see
where other people would and I don't
think there's that much inherently wrong
with it aside from like some of the
nitpicky stuff I talked about when I did
my review the first episode which I
assume is just me being really picky
thoughts on the new trailer with the
Cybermen called my doctor a Boomer okay
I think people are just messing with me
now ever seen the everything
Thanksgiving ever video hilarious video
everyone thinks Thanksgiving is about
family and food until the youngest kid
calls it out and calls out it's genocide
Alaura jhin's I mean I've never seen
that video but you know I've seen Addams
Family Values I'm well familiar with the
problematic origins and the
mythologizing around the holiday but I
also don't celebrate the holiday because
of its supposed origins I celebrate the
holiday because it's a good time with
family and good food and lots of wine
would you like to see the master and
Doctor Who yeah eventually and then new
trailer the and the new trailer Clara
returns on these are bluff because why
not sit see now you've tipped your hand
now I know you're messing with me so
there ever be a meet-up for council
members at a bar let's call it the
watering hole meet and greet I'm in a
dream world when I start to get out to
more conventions I'd love to arrange for
something like that but right now I get
to them so infrequently and like wow I'm
grateful for the audience I have you
know I'm still shy of 40,000 subscribers
and just given the spread of people like
a third of the people who watch me are
in the UK I think it's hard to pull too
many people together also I'm not used
to thinking about
Thumbelina and sound of music is now
Disney products oh when did they get
their hands on those did those used to
be Fox is that why they have those down
I don't know it's odd they own
everything now which master would you
like back what do you mean which master
would I like Brad could do a new one
they closed out the story for the last
for the other two for a modern era you
do a new master maybe do a meet-up at
Gallifrey one I mean I might float it
out there to see who else is gonna be
there I know of at least one person who
will be at Gallifrey one who I
absolutely plan to meet up with and
catch up and give a nice hug to but I
don't know who else is gonna be there
like if I can get a head count of who
else is gonna be there maybe I mean
we'll see they were they also got the
first two home alone movies well that
that I knew I remember those being Fox
productions which classic series stories
you've not seen but I'm most curious
about um
let me think um that's a good question
and I wish I had an answer to it I think
I'm actually most curious about
battlefield I've I've heard a lot of
very different things about that one
have you ever bought any products from
GUP not so far as I know planning on
hugging Reilly
would you watch super wholock well I
know what who log is I don't know if
super is like an added layer that I'm
not familiar with biggest example of
snake oil selling the entire nutritional
supplements industry just off that my
head that's an odd question so you know
what let me bring this into the into the
spirit of of the season a little bit
more express it a bit of thankfulness oh
it's short for Supernatural OC I don't
know Supernatural at all so I can't I
can't really help you there so I mean
obviously I let me get the obvious stuff
out of the way I am incredibly grateful
for you folks if you're watching if
you're commenting patreon share any of
it I as much as I you know I tend to
harp on you know the pushing hoping to
get this to where this could be my
entire job and you know and I hope I I
hold on to that I'm not gonna let go
that but the honest-to-god truth is is
that I have an audience that astounds me
in size in temperament I'm really proud
of the community that has been built at
this point and I don't want to say built
by me I think you folks have had
actually more to do with it than I have
because the most I can claim credit for
is is pulling weeds because you know I'm
not afraid to to block people if I think
it's necessary to do that but aside from
from trying to remove the bad elements
the community that I see in my comments
section in the discord in the patreon
here and the live streams with the same
people coming back that's amazing that
that is that is a level and a depth of
support that honestly just kind of blows
my mind so I'm I'm dang thankful for
that because you know I started doing
this on the presumption that nobody
watches and if that remained the case I
probably I'm not sure I can say I would
have stopped but I would have slowed
down but you folks make me feel a lot
more value in what I do and it makes me
want to do it more I got around to
seeing Joe Joe Rabbit it may well be my
favorite film this year Taika Waititi is
a master of comedy in this generation I
do want to see that I don't know if it's
gonna come around here excuse me
I'm thankful for the times when I make
you laugh
not gonna lie this channel has become my
happy place oh I'm glad to have you here
turns out that lin-manuel miranda is
going to have a cameo in Star Wars rise
of Skywalker okay and I did I I don't
think that cameo wise I don't think
they'll ever do better than the Daniel
Craig cameo cuz that was just that was
brilliant who do you think is coming
after the thirteenth doctor they most
assume oh you mean like hunting hunting
her most assumed of the Cybermen but
think he could be something from the
classic era like the valley ardor Omega
I like I'm not not a big speculator by
nature the the Cybermen would be an easy
hook in and the only reason I sort of
hesitate to think that it might be
anything else is then it becomes like oh
how many different things from the past
are you gonna bring in it's one thing to
bring in Athenee or two from the past
but if it's not the Cybermen and it's
not the the Scorpion type rack does that
it looks like we've got and presumably
it's not the Daleks so you know that
means that in addition to all that stuff
that we know is coming it's something
else
that is also coming back that we haven't
known at that point with only ten
episodes in series you were burying it
in old stuff and I kind of hope that's
not the case so if that is the case I
almost kind of hope it's the Cybermen
just so we're not getting an overload
I'd like to see the Ronnie come back and
maybe ready to be a better character cuz
I think she had some potential I mean I
guess there was potential in the concept
I just don't really know if there was
enough for it to be worth taking another
crack out you know I just I'm not gonna
say there was nothing there I just don't
even think that what she is a character
had the potential
to be is really all that interesting at
the end of the day and maybe part of
that has to do with the fact that I feel
like entrapped on Shira is like the best
version of that concept you know the the
nearly completely amoral scientist I
think I know what's coming after the
doctor on this series it's toxic fans of
the Daleks you layered that one nicely
done if you could recast the master who
you choose Cumberbatch Jude Law Tom
Hiddleston er Hugh Laurie well I mean if
you're gonna force me to choose one of
those I would give it to Lori because I
think he'd go more subdued with it which
I kind of want to see given that the
last two masters we've had were really
bombastic one in a way that I did like
one in a way I didn't but you know
that's all we've kind of gotten that
flavour twice now I'm thankful at all
but but if anyone steals any of my green
bean casserole there's going to be hell
to pay my daughter's mother introduced
me to green bean casserole that was not
a staple of my Thanksgiving Thanksgiving
when I was growing up um well actually
for me was largely about the pie because
oh boy I was an only child and at most
of the Thanksgivings I was at I was the
only child
there were like one or two were like my
uncle came and brought his kids who were
older than me
um but failing that like when they came
around um I was the only kid there and I
didn't like the pies that they would
make they'd make a pumpkin pie and a
mincemeat pie which I guess was
traditional for like my mother's
generation and her mother's generation
but I didn't like either of those so
they make me a chocolate cream pie
that was mine like other people had it
but like I knew it was there because of
me yeah and that was that was absolutely
the highlight when I was growing
I've expanded my palate a little bit
since then I want to see the celestial
intervention agency
according to Big Finish the CIA created
the valley our debt be interesting I
mean can they find something else to
call it cuz just calling it the CIA
always throws me off because you know
that's a real thing where I live I got a
lot of crawfish pies coming my way this
Thanksgiving I mean if you love them
grape like ah I don't mean to yuck
you're young I'm sorry that's like a gut
visceral reaction I'm really sorry I'm
thankful for the Doctor Who that the
Doctor Who fan base is a little better
behaved than the Star Wars fandom for
all their problems and you actually yeah
I kind of give you that at least death
threats aren't thrown towards the talent
well not with any massive regularity at
any rate
stuffing or dressing a stuffing here was
the funny thing stuffing is one of those
things that I thought I didn't like when
I was growing up but then when I got
older I realized I just I wasn't having
good stuffing but at this point like him
sothank Thanksgiving for me at this
point is five people it's me my daughter
her mother my daughters mother's
boyfriend and Liz and the five of us all
sit down and eat and my daughter's
mother does the cooking cuz she's
amazing at it and she makes the best
stuffing it is so good Oh Cass whoever
you'd like I'd love to hear your opinion
I mean the thing is right I'm not a I'm
not a dream caster by by nature I don't
really have a pick I much rather be
surprised by someone who I couldn't have
thought of how accurate do you think the
doctor who rumor is about female anchor
and about previous female incarnations
before Hartnell then I don't think that
holds water
I mean the thing is there were points in
the history of the show where it was
intended to be implied that Hartnell was
not truly the first incarnation of the
doctor but at this point they have
really locked that down I think it was
brain of Morbius that they implied that
there were other incarnations prior to
Hartnell but that that's really all been
shut down logistically there's no space
to sneak another incarnation in anymore
I really want philosophy tube to play
the master okay that that would be very
cool
oliver Thorne is the master I would like
even if it was like a rednose day thing
like just once I'd be very down for
saying that
I think Adrian Gillan would do great as
a more slimy scheming iteration even
though it'd be a bit unoriginal I don't
know who that is so that one I'm gonna
take your word I break out into a cold
sweat at random sometimes why do you
suppose that happens I don't know talk
to your doctor
Thanksgiving 2013 was really interesting
because it was the only time in my
lifetime where Thanksgiving in Hanukkah
happened at the same time oh very cool
I'm thankful I've lived this long
without telling the public I really
loved the last Jedi well you made it
this far had to end the streak sometimes
not the streak of not telling the public
the the stream of having lived to this
long because now you're going to be
hunted down and you know it's gonna be
very unpleasant so apologies for that
but it has to happen joking like hey I
always feel slightly annoyed having to
clarify that I'm joking but then at the
same time I'm like let's not risk it I'm
joking
did you agree I'm sorry did you see the
SNL high school theater sketch Will
Ferrell's drama teacher reminded me of
Snape um I haven't I don't really like
Will Ferrell like very much at all
so I gotta lock my doors that's that's
not that's cute that you think that'll
help Andrew but it if it makes if it
eases your your last few days well go
ahead you do that my mother made a
philadelphia cheesecake who would anyone
like a piece I what is substantively
what is the difference between
Philadelphia cheesecake in New York
cheesecake because I've heard them
referred to as separate things and I but
I think I've only ever had New York
style cheesecake so I don't actually
know what the difference is I don't want
to see the master again after the ending
of Missy stories I have no interest in
the seeing future master scene the
perfect way to end the character I mean
like I wouldn't mind I kind of chalk it
up to when it comes to long-running
villains that they're gonna come back
sooner or later I wouldn't have a
problem if that was the end of it but
like there's no way it's going to be
Adrienne Gillian was little a little
thing
from Game of Thrones that's why it'd be
a bit unoriginal choice the master yeah
hmm no I I'm not feeling that one I mean
I I can see it but I don't love it but
that's me lay a lesson at least huh
there we go at least let me live out my
vacation just give me a week look it's
out of my hands I don't know why he's
trying to negotiate with me
you have brought down the karmic hammer
this this is out of my hands man
I like to see James Nesbitt try than
master I know that name but I don't know
why when it comes to the master it's not
a matter of if but when he she comes
back boy yeah I I agree with that
I'm thankful I was able to restart my
life in Santa Fe where my bisexuality is
much more accepted and after moving here
I was able to help my aunt through a
very difficult time that Rea is
wonderful and thank you for sharing it
I'm super stressed because for the first
time I'm going to make an apple pie and
a sweet potato pie completely 100% from
scratch best of luck have wine on hand
have you ever heard that a host of Ben
Shapiro's daily wire with has attacked
mr. Rogers for corrupting I'm sorry for
corrupting boys with what he called
metrosexual wimpiness oh I've heard
conservative-leaning media personalities
make not that not those exact words but
make that claim that Mister Rogers was
somehow damaging to a generation by
telling people that they're special and
just the idea that some people think
that that's a bad thing that people
think that they matter that really
yeah I I don't I don't want this to turn
to political so I don't want I don't
want to get into I don't want to dig
into the the mindset behind stuff like
that too much I'm thankful for the
Mandalore dirt and Mandalorian baby Yoda
I want to know where the baby Oh to
merch is I I read that like it's now
coming I'm like how did you not have
that ready to go because baby Oda is
gonna be like number one you know geek
stocking stuffer
how are those not already made I feel
like they drop the ball I feel like the
same they happen with baby Groot that
like you should have been able to come
out of um guardians of the gap the first
guardians of the galaxy Frick say
nothing of grains the guys to do you
should have been able to come out of the
first guardians of galaxy and buy a
dancing baby Groot in the lobby on your
way out and like we had to wait months
for that like marketing people get on
your frickin game man I think man a lot
when I drink I don't know why did he
want to ask I move to Australia to live
out my remaining days with the spiders
the spiders are not gonna be any kinder
man and there it is again
how did blood what is going on do you
think the master should be played by a
British person only well yeah
same with the doctor I think because of
how closely those two are linked
basically it gets grandfathered in but
frankly I think the doctor should always
be played by a richer person so sadly
this isn't the first time mr. Rogers has
been maligned for being kind oh yeah
yeah I know if I work Chris Crocker I'd
make a video show how do you leave Fred
Rogers alone you bastards I don't think
you have to cuz I think the vast
majority of the human population just
goes yeah leave that leave him alone
like there have been very few perfect
human beings who have walked to this
earth but he's got to be in the running
like seriously
I've been watching Hannibal the TV
series it's got me really into cooking
[Laughter]
on that note I'd like to invite you over
for dinner sharpens knife oh goodness
if you are actually getting into
Hannibal I congratulate you because that
is a very cool show I love the last Jedi
- good thing I'm traveling over the
vacation to an undisclosed location I'm
pretty sure there is uh there is a
specific last Jedi branch of witness
relocation but seriously I'm happy for
my brother my happy my brother with my
two cats and myself are alive after my
house fire and I want a baby Yoda and a
date with the Mandalorian cheers to that
Donna I'm now laughing at the spiders
reacting angrily to the last Jedi so do
you think angry spiders do they just
sound like like the racnoss queen how
could you enjoy that film it'd ruin you
KY Walker
have you watched on corn Disney Plus
nope haven't even heard of it don't know
what it is I hope one day I'll have a
slice of turducken wha hey that whole
thing is one of the most bizarre
concepts I've ever heard of it's like if
memes were food I wish they would make a
real Steve Irwin movie like they've made
so many good ones about amazing people I
really think he deserves it um I
wouldn't be surprised if there's some
rights issues there because I know his
[Music]
his name His image
his story is pretty well protected by
his family and I don't mean that in like
God they wouldn't they'd like block a
film being made so it away but I think
anyone trying to make one would want
their go-ahead and they really seemed to
be holding a very tight control over his
legacy which probably is a hindrance to
getting a movie made
that's that speculation on my part but
out of gas there is a place where we who
like the last Jedi can hide far far away
from normal people in the shadows
we shall hide it's the rise of Skywalker
is good we know will happen I look for
as much crap as I give
I hope rise of Skywalker's good III
would that would make me very very happy
if it was I do think it was a poor
portrayal of Luke Skywalker from what I
understand even Mark Hamill had issues
with it but I had no control over it Oh
God why did I open this can of worms so
there's a rumor that Patton sends
Batsuit will be returned to classic blue
and gray Batman would this do you think
it'd be cool to take notes from Gotham
and make it dark and campy I mean I
don't even know what I want out of a
Batman movie at this point like I'm not
sure I would want that cuz like I've got
Gotham I don't think I need the movies
to be aping Gotham's you know aims and
aesthetic and approach it's a reality
show where former high school theater
kids come back to perform a show they
were in in the span of five days of
rehearsal with Broadway directors oh
that's kind of cool but I also don't
like reality television so I would
probably skip it anyway if memes were
food sounds like an all too realistic
dystopian story if you want to see a
good protection of glass Jedi watch the
video bye cosmonaut variety our look I
see I have seen and heard many well put
together defences and boosting Zand
praisings of the last jetta of the last
Jedi including by some people who I am I
consider to be friends
I still don't think it's good though I I
I'm sorry I just I don't very I think
part of the problem for me and this is
this comes up every now and then part of
the problem for me is that so many of
the things praising it don't address a
lot of the problems that I have with it
so that always puts me in an awkward
position because you know the early
reviews were just saying what they
thought was really good about it
cool I watched it had a lot of problems
but what makes it really awkward for me
is the problems I have are not the ones
that the most vocal parts of the fandom
have so what that means is whenever
somebody puts out a video defending the
last Jedi they're defending it against
the arguments I'm not making they're
defending it against the arguments of
the really loud people who are who are
really angry about things like ray and
Luke and like and I'm fine with most of
that I don't have the problems that the
defense videos are addressing and the
problems I do have I've never really
seen a decent defense mounted of either
because people don't other people don't
think that their problems or that they
don't think it's something that needs to
be addressed because it's not what
everyone else is shouting about we got
to get off Star Wars folks for real
Oh what are your problems then I have
multiple videos talking about the last
Jedi go dig them up I'm moving on
alright I'm not I've been trying to keep
up with the chat at this point some
stuff is whiz by me so if I missed your
question you may have to ask it again a
which film in your mind is the best out
of the MCU - Avengers still so much fun
to watch and great way to spend a Sunday
afternoon well I mean I I will always
distinguish between
best-in favorite because my favorite
might well still be spider-man
homecoming I think the best these days I
think I might make an argument for Civil
War i Captain America Civil War I also
like to fear her a lot love of monsters
kingdom of the crystal sauce Thor the
dark world Iron Man - stranger things -
why do I tell the public this because at
this point you're just baiting and you
know it clearly the master of it about
to finish listening to order the Phoenix
bit better when read by Jim Dale if you
ever listen to it be prepared for Lunas
voice I severely dislike Star Trek
Discovery but not for any reason that
some effed up haters had that somewhat
of a new thing with fandoms they're
getting hijacked by certain groups that
that is legitimate that is legitimately
a thing so somebody earlier said how
they're thankful that the Doctor Who
fandom has not you know gotten to the
level of sort of eating itself that the
Star Wars fandom has I think there is
there is a reality to that because I
think that so in both cases there are
look it's just it's just a fact that
there are trolling elements either for
fun
or because they think it actually
promotes something that they want to
have happen that overtake fandoms they
inject themselves into it they
infiltrate a fandom and then stir the
pot and really try and get things
falling apart and imploding and some
fandoms lend themselves to that a little
bit more depending on what buttons get
pushed so with Doctor Who the big button
push was female doctor ah and yet there
are some people who legitimately fans
who legitimately have a problem with
that
but I think time is is baring out that
not an especially high percentage of
fans of doctor who haven't had the
visceral inherent problem with that
there are some but there that wasn't a
huge sliver whereas was something like
the last Jedi people latched on to the
treatment of a character like Luke and
obviously a lot of people have a lot of
investment in how Luke gets treated as a
character so I think in that case
instigators were able to carve out a
larger slice of the fandom and so the
destruction has been a bit more severe
and Star Wars compared to say doctor who
was not staying
I've loved what's going on with Doctor
Who fandom in the last few years but you
know comparatively to everyone who says
they miss how doctor who used to used to
be congratulations you can go back and
watch it this is true ever gonna bring
back the green screen TARDIS um unlikely
the light I I don't know how I'm not
opposed to using the green screen again
and part of me would be really curious
to see how it would look at this point
because I'm using different editing
software then I was in a different
camera then I was when I used it
previously so maybe it would look better
now but the thing is just a pain in the
butt to set up and to use and I don't I
don't really have anything planned where
I want it enough it's one of those
things that like if I if I had somewhere
or a reason to set it up in a permanent
location then maybe but like the idea of
setting it up and taking it down I'm
like it's not worth it not for the kind
of videos I make so like I said it would
have to be some kind of special project
than maybe kind of like oh sorry kind of
like how the comm comics handled the
other theory explaining that it was the
11th doctor who ended up in the past
before Gallifrey ins had control over
time travel oh is that how they
ultimately retcon that cool I can roll
that because what what it was going to
be originally under
like the the Carmel master plan or
whatever was I did not like that idea at
all we are as strong as we are united as
weak as we are divided huh good quote
I liked sucker punch ooh I'll tell you
what sucker punch is a fascinating
failure of a film in my opinion I think
it's a mess but it's a really
interesting mess it's a mess I'm glad I
saw the one time but whoo that movie is
something else I'm actually gonna hop
back over to the to the discord real
quick obligatory plug reminder discourse
a patreon exclusive perk hop on over the
patreon links in the description whoo
self-promotion give me money I don't
know what that voice was uh hey I
thought Christmas was here already what
is this Thanksgiving Gabe so help me
maybe it's thanks for giving us more
Christmas ah I'm thankful for the
Council of geeks and for finding out
about it one weekend well in
Pennsylvania visiting my mother
oh I have really enjoyed the content of
live streams and has become a regular
part of my week oh thank you for that oh
and now we're sharing stories I found
council of geeks after YouTube kept
suggesting the why though Oh God kept
suggesting the why the doctor should
never be a woman video because of the
topic I was skeptical but thankfully I
watching that been a fan ever since oh
that's so funny to me that I've got
people who first how my channel because
of that video oh man I leave it up cuz
it's like it's a relevant artifact of
how I felt at the time that I made it
but Wow oh I wonder if it's that video
that snagged
it was definitely something about the
doctor being a woman I remember being
pleasantly surprised to hear a sensible
argument a such a divisive topic you
know I do my best
even even on things that I've since
changed my opinion on I still try and
represent myself well I found council of
geeks when I was looking for Doctor Who
videos that's after catching up on
Netflix before series 11 we are the
council and we have ignored the topic
they did a bit but I kind of loved it
tough topic I'm thankful for our little
community here and YouTube my online and
in real life friends my significant
other and family wonderful so to
continue I'm thankful also for my family
my friends that I have found some great
friends a few different online
communities and this one honestly I'm
thankful for your channel you give me an
escape hatch to go to your really
entertaining awesome and it's a boat
geez you guys Wow
I'm thankful for the council's ability
to explain queer issues in a way that
makes sense to us non queer people and
without being judgmental oh man
there I go saying man again I don't know
what is up with me tonight but so if I
have the live stream I'll be in media
the class second half I'll be at lunch
I'd like to say I'm thankful for the
caring thoughtful and playful community
we're building and the friends I've made
here also for the faith and trust they
Council of geeks and you all have placed
in me to protect and watch over it this
is this is Carolyn who is moderator so
yes she she has proven herself more than
worthy of that responsibility I'm very
thankful for Vera / Nathaniel um the big
effort they put into this wonderful
Channel thank you so much for your
kindness towards others that help others
to be kind to themselves also I'm
thankful for my husband who helps me
figuring out what
my help no who's helping me figure out
will my newly discovered sense for my
for my asexuality means for me and our
life I'm just glad that her husband's
supportive I think the thing is thankful
for his water oh geez New York style
cheesecake you can have with with coffee
and Philadelphia Philadelphia style
cheesecake uses Philly cream cheese ah
okay so anything else on Disney Plus
you're watching you're watching new no
I'm not not really not at this point
I'm thankful that you keep your channels
such a respectful place to chat with
others it's a really good environment to
have a civil conversation with others
I'm also thankful I enjoyed season eight
of Game of Thrones hey if you did that
is something to be thankful for
okay that's the discord I am back now ah
thankful for my family and friends
awesome
let's dance people of chat oh dear what
am I missing what were your thoughts on
endgame Thor it made sense as a
character but there were other ways they
could take the character I don't know I
have mixed feelings like my feeling
coming out of endgame was that they
overplayed the the weight thing but I
also say that as someone who's in
relatively who more or less meets the
current standards of beauty and nearly
everyone I know who is a person of size
thought it was awesome so I think I'm
just kind of shrug and go it seemed to
connect with the with the people who I
would have been concerned would have
been hurt by it so I'm gonna default to
them Isle of Man of Steel I will never
hide from it there are some interesting
confessions going on in here so okay
with what went on in the discord I'm now
kind of curious folks that folks on the
livestream what either what was the
first video of mine that you
saw or maybe if you saw a couple things
here and there what was the one that
convinced you to subscribe I'm kind of
curious consider this to be a snap poll
have you ever watched the extras on in
gaming him so which was your favorite I
haven't as yet
I'm thankful yet somehow very regretful
for being the one to start the of the
topics running joke Sucker Punch needed
that bit of gut punch too so tragic
consequences at the end and the thematic
coherence a good end would make it a
truly not forgettable movie I don't
think secre bunch is forgettable
I remember that thing I'm thankful for
finding this channel as it's nice to
watch Doctor Who and other reviews from
someone who can formulate their negative
opinions in a way that doesn't upset me
I consider that to be the highest
compliment thundercats vid was the first
one I saw oh man see like that makes me
smile because that isn't really even one
of the more well viewed ones that had
pretty low views on that so the idea
that that was something that that one
was somebody's first that is that is
really cool I think the first video I
saw was the gay Dumbledore video which
was odd considering I'm not a big Harry
Potter person but I love LGBT discussion
very cool the channel asks them and the
queerbaiting
yeah I had those kind of kind of come up
back-to-back and they both they both
blew up on me a bit so that ones that's
not too surprising I just got here what
does your mug say my mug says gender is
imaginary
I saw the Doctor Who videos first of
yours and it brought me to your channel
not sure of the specific one
Oh fair enough there's a lot of those
you can't remember was a Doctor Who and
I suspect this gonna be the case for a
lot of people Doctor Who really can't
remember which I think it was on
hell-bent I remember that I was that I
just watch this - bag full video the ho
first one I saw I think would have been
your hell-bent rant I don't remember for
sure okay so that would have been the
worst episodes written by Steven Moffat
video because yeah that's where that's
where I went full rant on that thing
generally when people talk about my
hell-bent rant that's the one they're
talking about not the two videos I
actually made reviewing the episode
proper because how much I hate hell bent
heads more solidified since I did the
hose let's see sorry I'm trying to back
up was a while ago would have been
something about Capaldi maybe I can't
recall I know it started with your
series 10 reviews I think you stay I
think I stayed on with either your
ranking the doctors are the master
videos or your Big Finish stuff I'm sure
was doctor who related yep
that tracks I just got my brother to
subscribe he likes your intelligent take
on things all thanks Donna I found you
because you do keppra mending your
recent rankings of the various
incarnations of the doctor some too
sometimes the algorithm does me a solid
not always but sometimes I don't
remember what who probably have been
Buffy related oh that that's not even
that many options that love your content
in your hair thank you your response to
the news of Jodie Whittaker okay
first counseling games damn that will
take some scrolling through my likes
I don't remember which video made me
subscribe I remember watching the
channel awesome video and then checking
out some Doctor Who videos yeah again
that that one did pretty well for me
said it before but my first video yours
I saw was Harry Potter and the heroine
or heteronormative standard it was very
good I'm proud of that one I'm proud of
my like I do I'm not ashamed I don't
think of any of the videos I have up but
there's some of them that I'm like yeah
I did real good that day ah yep Doctor
Who videos The Critic that shall not be
named yeah Doctor Who videos yep that's
coming up a lot love the mug thank you
I don't even remember what the first
video I saw if you was any more I've
been following you for two years at this
point oh so yeah lot lots of
possibilities that could be things
doctor who needs to stop doing I think
that was the first video I saw subscribe
the same day if I remember right that's
that is my most viewed video to date but
unicorns aren't imaginary right no a
court Andrew come on everyone knows
unicorns are real it's a joke grant your
video autoplay dear regenerations ranked
video when I was half-asleep I was at a
Whovian before I am now after I heard
you talk about Matt Smith and and loved
thank you very much oh wow that's cool
have you seen has been hotel nope I do
not know what that is
how's Liz no one asks about Liz Liz is
very well Liz has a pretty easy week
because you know short school I think
they're actually already done like I've
got work tomorrow she doesn't so liz is
doing quite well same for me Doctor Who
video but don't remember which that said
I've come to appreciate your LGBT themed
videos a lot too that's great to hear
found your channel channel view your
representation videos cool first one I
ever watch was about the two fantastic
beasts and them not going for with
Dumbledore being gay then the Lion King
review I really liked your take on
things that's that's one of my more
successful ones from this year and I
haven't had a ton of occasion to get
really angry this year at least I don't
think that one was an angry one though
I tried very hard not to force the anger
even though like I think a lot of people
like connect when I do that like people
still talk about the hell-bent rant as
an example or how shouty I got at the at
the end of the queerbaiting video but I
try very hard not to force that if it's
gonna happen it has to happen
organically but yeah hi King King was a
that was a rant he won I'm a goldfish so
I don't recall which video it
specifically was but looking at your
uploads it had to be over two years ago
that is crazy to me that some people are
still following me
yo it was it would have been come
January it'll have been two years since
I came out on the channel huh
I thought about that so anyone who's
been following me for two years or more
as of right now you watched me before I
was out how crazy is that out publicly
and any right I just look back to my old
account to try and figure it out I
caught on right after series 10 it was
either your video and Jodie Whittaker
announcement or your doctor Falls video
I found you because I'm I was watching
movie reviews best movies of the year
and whoo-whee and re-watched your Doctor
Who videos later seeing you on the BBC
commercial that hahahaha that's great
that you found me after noticing that
that was a bit of a snafu though that
whole thing that that wasn't supposed to
happen I can't remember if I've talked
about that or not your earlier video
show how much you've grown
oh thank you Donna I do think the seen
an end game where Thor gets his old
hammer back made fat Thor worth it for
me it was a beautiful heartbreaking
moment also I like that like getting his
hammer didn't suddenly make him not that
way again that would have been that
would have been cheap I remember
watching your coming-out video so it
must have been before that when I
started watching mm-hmm been around for
a year or so before that video yeah
definitely a difference and I remember
it was the ghost in the shell'
controversy oh man people hammered me
for that oh that was before even that
was before the movie even came out and I
did the video on the controversy people
were hating on me too hard for just the
fact that I said the movie looked like
it wasn't gonna be very good and then it
came out and it wasn't very good
Charcot shocks I called it first video
was the one they and the one that got me
to subscribe was well why is the lgbtq+
representation so hard mm-hmm how did
you decide to start to start at the
council and where did you get the name
okay it's it's been a while since I've
told this story so make it real quick
the name comes because originally this
wasn't just me yelling at a camera
originally this was a series of scripted
shorts and the council geeks referred to
the group of friends they was about and
that was that was why the channel had
that name I started doing the me ranting
at the camera initially as just a way to
have content in between scripted seasons
of that but then I eventually burned
through my scripted stuff
wasn't cranking out new scripts very
quickly and so the me rambling out the
camera became the default mode of the
thing I kept the name council of geeks
for two reasons the first being it was
kind of serving as a reminder to myself
initially that I wanted to have other
people on as much as I could but
unfortunately that has become harder and
harder to do as my regular collaborators
had kids and but now as is exemplified
by the sign-off somebody actually
suggested in the comments a while back
that it was the commenters the
subscribers the supporters who are the
council and I basically adopted that as
the mantra and I'm not the council you
folks at the council been here for more
than two years I remember the Q&A where
you came out it was like two years ago
just another two years another two or
another two Thank You Ben
I'm coming in happy anniversary by the
way thank you very much I don't remember
the topic but the first video I saw of
you I just assumed your tape would fall
under the knee-jerk toxic masculinity so
coming to geek channels boy was I
pleasantly surprised I've actually heard
that more than a bit I think in some
ways I don't think it actually actively
like ever hurt me but I do think some
people I've heard it for more than a few
people that they were reluctant to click
on my videos because the way I present
most of the videos ie with the hat I'm
you know am my hair up and the geeky
stuff behind me it was ringing the bell
of a lot of geek channels that just were
the kind of thing they didn't like and
like they had to have my stuff
recommended to them a lot before they
were like fine we'll try it and then I
ended up not being what they thought
which happy to surprise people I tend to
rather frequently end up not quite being
what people think having kids lame yeah
I know right so bogus I know I turned to
do a surfer dude
we're the Fez that's on the owl for the
rest of the stream pretty please not
that this Hedwig's Fez I've got my own
and send the closet oh boy that's a
talking about my coming out oh I do surf
I've never never sir I've never even
tried to serve the term geeks has gained
some negative connotation thanks to
select group of channels yeah fair
enough
rocking the bathroo hope fezzes are cool
what's the name of your coming-out video
okay if you go it's actually it's not to
be doing dedicated explicitly to that
but it comes up at the end so my it's my
10,000 subscriber Q&A video from January
2018 uh
tail end of that I forget well but it
was the last question I answered
resulted am i coming out on the channel
yeah so was the first time I let my hair
down I mean like you go further back you
can see my hair but there's a very long
stretch where it's always under the hat
because I you know had it styled in a
way that was more gender bendy and I
stuffed it under I had not completely to
hide it part of it was just to maintain
an image but another part of it was it
meant I didn't have to style it made my
life easy that's actually the original
reason why the Hat came into play was
because it meant I didn't have to fix my
hair if it wasn't agreeing and then it
just became a look so this January your
friends is going to come out in a QA ah
very funny it's about the last 10
minutes of the 10000 video yeah that
sounds about right
Oh Oh the and I have a stake in in the
race moment with the hare who are the
other people in the council geeks logo
okay
so right now there are three other
people this is in the updated logo
that's now up so I'm still front and
center behind me to my left is Liz who
actually does appear every now and then
to my right is Ryan who has been in one
video this year and then behind Liz is
Paul who hasn't been in a video since
2018 and Paul and Ryan were my most
regular appearing guests but like I said
they now both have kids actually Paul
now has two kids
so trying to wrangle everybody is just
not practical these days I still love to
get them on again and I mean there are
other people I'd like to have on I I
would love so like oh god while back
can't even remember when it might have
been 2017 can't remember now I I had a
podcast project that I called go home
Hollywood you're drunk which which I
thought was really good people it didn't
like get big but people her who heard it
seemed to really like it a lot and my
co-host on that John van Lully you might
be noticing a recurring theme here had a
kid and schedule he became a lot harder
but I like I wanted to get him on camera
for a long time but like he's even less
local than Paul and Ryan are when he and
I were podcasting together he I used to
have to have him Skype in so you know I
mean the problem is I live in the middle
of frickin nowhere
and when my free time is comes in weird
times and days so that's the ultimate
hurdle to a lot of this I watched about
60% of your videos on here in about 45
percent or so from your veera channel I
just started on your new channel Wow
that is an impressive amount like cuz on
here I've got over a thousand videos on
this channel have you seen any of the
BBC HBO dark materials series can't
recommend I haven't yet
I will be I've been commissioned to so
yeah that that is gonna be coming up
next month I'm gonna talk about em hmm I
don't know if I'll do the whole series
I've been commissioned to do the whole
series but we'll see if it gets me in
enough the the person who it's actually
funny because somebody commissioned me
to review the first two episodes then
someone else came in to commissioned me
to review the first two episodes and I
told him someone else had and they went
oh okay well can i Commission you to
review the second two episodes so I'm
commissioned for the first four episodes
of His Dark Materials but the funny
thing is the person who commissioned me
the first time I feel like they are
setting me up here a bit because they
actually reached out to me and said I
think it'll be right up your alley it
has a prophecy and a chosen one and
depending on which of my videos you see
nor would you write tweets you've
noticed or whatever I have a strong
distaste and I'm Way completely sick and
over prophecy narratives and chosen one
narratives so the fact that they pointed
out makes me think that they might be
setting a fox loose among the chickens
we will find out because I've never read
the books and I didn't see the Golden
Compass although that was probably for
the best in any case I'm gonna have to
wrap it up soon folks I have an
uncontroversial Star Wars question
favorite lightsaber
color although if you choose red that
could be controversial and ah I mean
mines red that should maybe be your
first clue I don't know though
like I don't the the reason I have a red
one isn't because I'm like breads the
best is because that is specifically
modeled after Darth Vader's lightsaber
and that's what I wanted um I don't know
if I would like hat truly have my own
and like could get a color any color I
wanted not necessarily one that's been
done or you know been in the films or
whatever I don't know I'm being climbed
to say green but you know I I never
liked the design of the handle for
Luke's green lightsaber in Return of the
Jedi never liked it so but if I could
design my own handle on that yeah
probably Green I love your channel it
discusses geeky topics without people
being children and scream me about just
because it's always been a certain way
it means it has to stay that way
yeah nothing yet nothing has to stay the
same although if you're gonna change
it'd be good to have a reason just does
a rule of thumb I so I'll fight like a
girl t-shirt yesterday thought of you I
live in Australia so it was quite a
surprise oh very cool uh very random
question for anyone any recommendations
for a good we game and I I have a Wii
but I got it secondhand like it was
basically gifted to me because someone
else was done with it I never really had
the time to to get into it much have you
read The Watchmen graphic novel what do
you think about I have I've read
Watchmen Watchmen the graphic novel is
immaculate it is impeccable watch when
the movie is one of the biggest freaking
thorns in my side I really hate it
and if it wasn't so like completely not
topical and nobody cares I
I would so devote like a 40 minute video
explaining why friggin I hate it again
largely because the reasons I hate it
are not the ones that other people who
don't like it
site so I think it's an interesting
conversation I don't know nobody
nobody's asking so and and I don't yet
have I don't yet have the level of
support where I can pull like an h-bomb
or guy and devote a long video to
something just cuz it's what I want to
talk about maybe one day but yeah not
yet do you hear DC license credit cards
yes we're getting a back credit card one
of the reasons I watched Gotham was so
that I could watch your reviews Wow I
was very bothered that I couldn't watch
all of your videos and of course because
you recommended it oh that is awesome
maybe a purple lightsaber maybe I don't
know it's I tend to see the thing is
lightsabers tend to look best when
they're brighter colors and when it
comes to purple I prefer deeper shades
so I don't know in the new year I might
pay a hundred dollars to get you to read
and review another culture book with
more LGBTQ stuff in it this one would be
about 450 pages long I tell you man the
books I've been commissioned on so far
you people are not messing around I'm
I'm I'm in the homestretch of the of a
book I got Commission's that I can do
the review next month but after that I
got commissioned it to read a george RR
martin book like i ha you folks who
commissioned books out of me you're
killing me like it's a nice problem to
have but dang somebody come extra
novella don't watch the Golden Compass
movie it's awful I've heard after
watching the first two episodes of His
Dark Materials I don't think I ever want
to see the movie
I think I've liked all your videos by
now because I swear it will protect you
from the algorithmic I will protect you
from the algorithm if it kills me
uh-huh a mood lightsaber changes color
with every mood ooh okay I could go with
that like especially if like it turns
red when I'm pissed off
so like I've got the lightsaber out it's
I don't know it's it's a nice blue it's
a green and then you know somebody just
does the wrong thing it goes red and
everyone's like oh crap that would be
very cool what's your least favorite
movie ever I don't know why I honestly
don't I can tell you what the first
movie was that I remember hating
not just disliking but hating and it was
dead man with Johnny Depp Jim Jarmusch
film I hated it so much that's the first
time I remember like loathing a movie
I'd be angry that I spent time watching
it I'm certainly finding the watchmen
HBO series interesting Jeremy Irons is
really fun I mean I'm only morbidly
curious about that I've actually has
been kind of surprising that almost
nobody's been asking me am i watching
that so I'm kind of getting the
impression that it's maybe not the big
splash everyone thought it was gonna be
favorite pro now drink Oh
very thing is gonna be out next month
the the book review of heroin yes it'll
be out last month I next month I've got
like I'm like 80% done with the thing I
it will be done next month
have you read Carmilla I have not well
you take four cents to read a book
that's all I've got
ha ha I like your channel so much I
turned off my adblock err oh wow that's
like the highest praise you can give and
I will take it I can feel the seething
rage through my screen mr. robot I
watched the first two episodes of mr.
robot I was commissioned to I liked it
well enough just I've been which is not
enough to keep with it uh me says I like
the last Jedi your lightsaber rather
than my face my till the lunch lady to
also enjoy her lunch oh goodness
got a - have a happy Thanksgiving to you
in yours and that goes to Carolyn and
everyone huh I really hated the Eragon
movie I never saw I've never read the
book so no no dog in that race I should
I should wrap it up yes and thank you
Donna thank you for stopping in
favorites steampunk story I I haven't
actually read a steampunk story
I love steampunk as an aesthetic I've
read like a couple of steampunk ish like
comic book stuff like a very Girl Genius
but I haven't read like steampunk novels
or prose I just I I just love the
aesthetic of it that's kind of where my
relationship with steampunk begins it
ends for the most part
I know I don't have water to drink if
that's important you gotta hydrate after
the stream I'll have a list of things
that are universally hated that I loved
putting a hundred targets on my back but
oh well
I prefer cyberpunk I like cyberpunk but
I've also been liking cyberpunk since
the 90s so I've kind of moved past it a
little bit not like I never want to deal
with it again kind of level of having
moved past it but like I feel like I got
what I was gonna get out of cyberpunk
favorite video game Final Fantasy 6 I
don't even have to think about that one
worst movies Freddy got fingered out see
I've never seen that and it won't last
somebody pays me
have you ever excuse me have you ever
tried tofurkey have not what do you
think of the Weeping game will angels
being Time Lords theory I think that
entire hint that was in hell bent was
stupid and pointless and offhanded and
added nothing and I haven't paid
attention to the theories cuz I don't
care you know if you said you wouldn't
read and review player I was planning on
getting you to read to read the worst
moment ya could think of oh boy
something I have been commissioned in
the past by people who brought me on
specifically to watch something that
they didn't think I would like cuz they
wanted me to tear it apart
but be careful cuz thats backfired the
person who commissioned me to review the
first season of titans did it cuz they
hated it and they hoped I would too and
it didn't so you know if you're planning
to try and torment me or set me loose on
something to tear it apart be careful
and also be careful if your
commissioning me because you hope I
really like it or it's the things you
really like because I'm pretty sure I've
broken a few hearts by tearing into
something that that whoever commissioned
me really loves I'm gonna I'm gonna
approach the same way I approach
everything do you think other villains
will be used in in Joker like films and
would it work or is Joker's character
unique to that kind of story um I'm not
sure there's a ton of villains that will
that will that will work in a standalone
separate from the heroes they're usually
put in conflict with there was rumor of
I mean it might still be happening a
Kraven the hunter movie that my eats
work depending on the origin go they go
with
but yeah off the top of my head I don't
really have any notions on that I mean
the thing is most villains are designed
to exist within the conflict with the
hero they're not designed to be
standalone entities that's not to say
they can't be but like that's not how
they're built in the first place so the
whole idea is just strikes me as odd
you've never torn into something I've
loved looks at the master three part
finale two series three in Christ I know
enough about your taste that I'm willing
to roll the dice oh well fair have you
watched will you watch umbrella Academy
I did I saw the first season I didn't do
a review because by the time I finished
it it like it wasn't all that topical
anymore I didn't binge it like through
when I first went out um I had nitpicks
but I liked it well enough I'm looking
forward to another season
I don't watch your videos to agree with
I watch them because of how you present
your thoughts and of course the
entertainment value you show biz I'm out
of water I am 20 minutes over my usual
stopping point i-i-i think we are due to
wrap it up so thank you very much for
being here for watching for talking to
me for letting me talk to you ah this
this is a this is a bright little island
of my week and I really enjoy it thanks
everybody I hope you have a great
Thanksgiving if you live in a part of
world that doesn't celebrate it I hope
you have a good rest of the week and
just remember that you are beautiful you
are valid you are loved
you are the council I just run meetings
sometimes at a great big warm fuzzy
bathrobe Happy Thanksgiving